>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Wow!
>> Nicholas Brown: Welcome.
Thank you for sticking
around for our Post Concert
Nightcap Conversation.
Fortunately, there is no festive
beverage to accompany that,
but we'll do the best we can to get
out of here soon so we can get that.
So, I'm very thankful to all of
you for joining us this evening.
It was really a spectacular concert.
Thank you to the musicians for
being phenomenal, of course.
Feel free to clap.
[ Audience Applause ]
Thank you.
And so if you wouldn't
mind introducing yourselves
and maybe give a bit
about your background
and what your main jobs are these
days, whether some of you are
with orchestras or doing
Chamber music; more are teaching
or just teaching as soloists.
>> Lydia Brown: Start with me?
>> Nicholas Brown: Sure.
>> Lydia Brown: Hi.
My name is Lydia Brown.
I'm a pianist, and I do a
lot of work with singers
in any capacity that I can do it.
I'm working at the Metropolitan
Opera and San Francisco Opera,
and I've recently joined the staff
of the Cincinnati College
Conservatory of Music,
where I coach singers all
day long, and I'm just,
I've always been happiest
when they were around.
So, I'm glad to have been
overseeing the vocal program evolve
over the last ten years, and
that was actually really one
of the greatest gifts that I was
ever given to me was the chance
to be able to work with
singers, the young singers,
seven weeks every summer, and we do,
you know, this kind of repertoire,
and then also vocal ensemble
with only piano, and to me,
it's like my greatest joy.
>> Rebecca Albers: I'm Becca Albers.
My main job, I guess, is
Assistant Principal Violist
of the Minnesota Orchestra, and I
also play a lot of tuber music in
and around Minnesota and, I guess,
around the rest of the country.
But and then I also teach, actually,
at McAllister College and St. Paul
and also down at the Robert
McDuffie Center for Strings
at Mercer University in Georgia.
So, I go down there three
times a month usually.
I'm going in a couple of days,
in the middle of the tour,
but it's nice to have a lot
of variety in what I'm doing.
>> Alice Yoo: Hi.
>> The mike, [inaudible] the button.
>> Alice Yoo: Hello.
Okay. My name is Alice Yoo.
I am originally from Montana,
and I was living in New York
until this past year when I
moved to Denver, Colorado,
and I've been playing with the
[inaudible] Symphony for the last,
I guess, four, five months,
and fairly new there.
So, I really love it
there, and I'm happy.
>> Carmit Zori: Carmit Zori,
I'm originally from Tel Aviv,
and I play chamber
music for a living,
and I teach at Rockford
University, part-time,
and also at Purchase College.
That's it.
>> Michelle Ross: I'm Michelle Ross.
I live in New York.
I was born in California,
and I guess I do a little bit
of everything these days; lots
of chamber music and some solo
and sometimes some guest
concert master work,
which is really fun,
and I also compose.
>> Nicholas Phan: I'm Nick
Phan, and I just travel
around being a guest soloist
mostly with various orchestras,
opera companies, [microphone
noise] microphones.
Yeah, and that's what I do.
>> Nicholas Brown: So,
and I'm Nick Brown.
I'm the concert producer
of this evening's concert.
I've worked with some
great colleagues
in the concert office here,
and apologies for not introducing
myself at the beginning.
Just a reminder that we are being
filmed for this Conversation
so that you can tell all your
friends and send them a link later
on that you heard some
great insights
from the musicians this evening.
All right.
So, the first thing
I'd love for us to talk
about is the Marlboro Process
for from putting concerts
and repertoire together in the
summer, where you come from all
over the country or all over the
world into that setting; and then,
you bring things back on tour.
So, what is that experience like for
you all with the big gap in between?
>> Carmit Zori: Big gap.
What do you mean by that?
>> Nicholas Brown: As in, was this
program originally performed this
past summer?
>> Carmit Zori: A portion of
the program was performed.
>> Nicholas Brown: Okay.
Cool! So, what's the experience for
you to put it together in the summer
and then come back together
after may not seeing each other
since that summer season?
>> Carmit Zori: Well, we're
all sensitive musicians,
and we like to work hard,
and what we do in the summer,
it's like an orgy of chamber music,
and so when we are actually meeting
it's like meeting old friends,
and it's a big party of hard work,
and it's incredibly rewarding.
So, yeah, that's what
it's like; it's very nice.
>> Nicholas Phan: I had
the [inaudible] position
of joining this group because when
they performed this three summers
ago it was with a different
tenor, who was not actually able
to do the tour in the end.
So, I, as a former alum,
was, they called me next,
and I performed this
piece, The [inaudible]
in particular many times,
and what was so nice
about coming together this week
was it's generally hard to find
that sort of group sound somehow,
and jumping into this,
they all had it already.
So, all I had to do was
just sort of dive in,
and it's been a really luxurious
experience to be working
with these lovely ladies
this past week.
>> Nicholas Brown: Great.
>> Rebecca Albers: Mutual.
>> Nicholas Phan: Thank you.
>> Rebecca Albers: It's worth
mentioning that the piece
that this tour was arranged
around was the Vaughan Williams,
and so everything else
on the program is new
to us as a, as an ensemble.
>> Nicholas Brown: Where
is this tour taking you,
and where will you go next together?
>> Rebecca Albers: We started in
Boston at the Gardiner Museum,
and then we were at Wyle
[phonetic], at Carnegie on Monday.
Tomorrow, we're in
Philadelphia, and then we're
in Greenwich, Connecticut on Sunday.
>> Nicholas Brown: Okay.
What do you think about
your sort of unique set
of professional experiences
as individuals?
You come from from different
backgrounds, right, and you do a lot
of different things in different
combinations, and some of that,
is it similar between each of you?
What do you bring to the
table when you meet together?
So, does one of you as more
of an [inaudible] player have a
certain personality versus Nick
as the touring tenor might have a
different personality, you know?
>> Nicholas Phan: Oh, no.
Be nice.
>> Nicholas Brown: Or
does that not matter?
>> Nicholas Phan: Which
is it [inaudible] casting.
>> Lydia Brown: I don't know.
I mean, I think, you know, we
all, what binds us, what binds us
and bonds us is music,
and so somehow I think
in a way our outside
experiences, in a way, we , I hope,
I think they just inform
who we are as people
and who we are as musicians.
And when we're all
in a room together,
I think it's just we're just dealing
with the notes and the feelings
between the notes, and I
think somehow, I don't know,
it kind of simplifies things,
you know, as kind of the rest,
at least for me, kind of falls
away, and it's just five of us and,
you know, six of us, and
we're just there trying
to kind of unearth some answers.
And so, I don' know, I
guess for me personally,
I feel a little bit
less kind of overwhelmed
by other [inaudible] the opposite.
My feelings are more just about
this is what we're here to do,
and let's find it together.
Yeah.
>> Michelle Ross: What's so amazing
about Marlboro is that everyone is
at a different point in their
life, their age, their career,
wherever they are professionally
around the world,
but the thing that matters is what
kind of musicianship you bring,
and I actually think it's
kind of the other way around.
It's like that's the standard
for us is playing chamber
music with each other.
So, whether or not in our
real lives we're, you know,
outside of the Marlboro oasis
where in an orchestra or teaching,
it's the musicianship
that you're bringing
to every single one
of those situations.
So, all of your experiences and the
composite experiences is amazing
because everyone, just
because of everyone's,
the variety of personality and
perspective regardless is going
to bring something to the table.
But I think what's so
amazing about Marlboro
and what it inspires
is this absolute focus
on what's important
about making music.
So, to be able to do the tour
in the middle of the year is
like for me it's just this gift of,
a reminder of what it's like to be
so inspired and challenged by your
colleagues and by the composers
and the works and to have this
almost impossible task of, you know,
making, bringing what, as
much as we can to each other
and to the music and
to the performer.
So, it's a gift to be able to
do that in this little mini way.
>> Carmit Zori: I think,
and to add to this,
is I think we all respect
each other, and it's,
the rehearsal period is and
concerts from one to another is
like an intellectual and
emotional feast, you know.
That's what's so, it's just lovely!
>> Nicholas Brown: That's great.
That's what we love to hear.
The last person I'm going
to ask before we turn it
over to audience [inaudible] is
about the Vocal Chamber
Music repertoire.
So, we had the Vaughan Williams,
which was just spectacular,
and also the Beethoven, which
is probably something that few
of us have ever heard before,
but is really exciting to hear.
How do you approach the Chamber
Ensemble plus voice repertoire
differently than non-voice
repertoire, or non-vocal repertoire?
>> Lydia Brown: I mean,
I can start this.
I'm sure Nick has a lot to say too.
But I think, I've, personally,
I always feel like the pianist
and the singer are kind of the core
even within local chamber music.
And so, I always oftentimes
at Marlboro,
I'll rehearse with the
singer just with piano.
It depends on the piece,
but I mean I think that only
if the singer feels like
they have that as a place
where they can always, you know,
be at one with that instrument.
So, it kind of keeps the song
aspect of it kind of central.
And then, I think, after that,
you know, it's kind of trying
to find the reasons that the
instruments exist based on the text,
and then everything
goes around that.
But I just feel from my own
experience that if you start
from that singer, piano
kind of core, it helps.
>> Rebecca Albers: Well,
I think having the text is
maybe the biggest difference
because it brings it completely --
I mean, for us, it's sort of a
foreign element and just thinking
about how the text relates to
every little gesture and line,
it's a different starting
point; I think,
ultimately, a different result.
>> Nicholas Phan: Yeah,
but the text,
music is such an abstract
thing by itself.
You know, it's an abstract way of
expressing an abstract emotion,
and maybe a composer, most likely,
a composer has something
specific in mind.
But you know, it's left to us
to sort of infer and guess and,
you know, if we're lucky,
read a book about it,
or something, if that exists.
But the text makes
the abstract concrete,
and that is a huge
difference, I find.
I think the other challenge,
the biggest challenge with it is
that it's hard to find singers who
can feel comfortable in that setting
because we start late, you know,
we have to wait for our bodies
to finish changing, and so a lot
of singers come to music very late
when all of you guys have been
doing it since they were four,
and most singers probably
don't start until they 16, 17,
and 18; sometimes, even later.
And it creates a different
kind of relationship with music
for most singers, I think.
And then there are a few of us,
like me, where I actually started
like you guys when I was four,
and I tried really poorly
to play their instruments.
So, for me, doing the vocal chamber
music actually is a real big passion
for me because it allows me
to reconnect with what kind
of made me fall in love with
music in the first place as a kid.
I mean, I used to love reading
[inaudible] string Quartets
and whatever, and it probably
sounded absolutely horrifying.
But it was fun, and that's kind
of why I wanted to be a musician,
so it's, these moments are really
luxurious for me personally
because it's like, ah, you
know, stop being a singer
and just kind of be one of the gang.
It's fun.
>> Carmit Zori: One more thing that
happens when we play with singer
or probably wood bits also, any
kind of thing that they're different
from us is that we have to learn how
to adjust the kind of sound we do
and make sure that his words or her,
whoever is singing with us, come,
and it's a different click for us.
Wonderful!
>> Nicholas Brown: Great.
A slight follow up question,
so when you have a piece
like the Vaughan Williams, do you
let Nick present an interpretation
of the text, and then
you kind of respect that?
Do you work collaboratively?
Do you all do close readings of the
text, or is it just an organic thing
that happens in rehearsals?
>> Chamber music, chamber music.
>> Nicholas Phan: We had a lot of
discussions, and actually it was
so nice to have this week, the time
this week to have those discussions.
It's kind of the Marlboro way.
You have to ask a lot of
questions, and it's great.
>> Nicholas Brown: Awesome!
Great! So, we'll open the
floor up to all of you.
If you could just raise your
hand, and my colleague, Simon,
will bring over a microphone,
and we'll try and get a few
of these in tonight before we go.
>> Great. Aye.
>> Thank you.
I'm, well, first, let me say I
enjoyed the whole concert tonight.
I certainly enjoyed the
instrumental parts tremendously.
The Razumousky was great and the
Haydn was great, and I would really
like it if you'd expand
a little bit more
on Nicholas Brown's question
about the vocal parts.
First of all, have
either the Beethoven
or the [inaudible] been
recorded very much before?
How well known are these?
They're not well known to me.
I remember that last year or the
year before, you had a program here
at the library that featured
George Thompson works
for the Haydn did the
instrumental music for.
That was a really great program.
I don't remember from that that
Thompson had written anything or,
I'm sorry, had asked anybody else,
but apparently, he asked a lot
of other people to help him out,
and Beethoven is one of those.
So, is this, how well known is this?
Has this been widely recorded,
either the Beethoven leader,
or for that matter, the Vaughan
Williams, is that widely recorded?
>> Nicholas Phan: So, the Vaughan
Williams is an extraordinarily
popular piece in the UK, and
there are a ton of recordings.
If you search on Spotify, you'll
probably find at least five.
The Beethoven is less recorded, but
there is a complete recording on DG
with Malcolm Martineau and
a bunch of British singers
and two beautiful players.
So, the recordings do exist.
They're not, it's not quite
as widely known and, I mean,
I think we focus on other things by
Beethoven like the Ninth Symphony,
or other things of that ilk.
Yeah, exactly.
So, I just think that's
why it's not as known,
as other works sort of overshadow.
They cast a giant shadow
and, you know,
you have to be really interested
in Beethoven to kind of --
>> Right.
>> So, when you put
together a program
like this general chamber
music audience, okay,
you can be pretty sure that
if it includes vocal music
like this, it'll be well received.
People, they're going
to like it, and so.
>> Nicholas Phan: We hope so.
[Laughing] I'm sorry.
I don't mean to dominate this
conversation, but my take on,
I've founded an organization
in Chicago called Collaborative
Arts Institute of Chicago,
and the mission of the organization
is to promote vocal chamber music
and art song because that
is like the dustiest corner
of the classical music world.
And that, this particular music I
think is kind of losing its audience
because of just, you know, the way
technology and the way we relate
to music and listen to music and
discover music has changed because,
as we were saying before,
with texts,
so much of vocal music really
relies on what is the singer saying;
otherwise, it just sounds like
a singer is shouting at you
in some language for 20
minutes, and you're like, why?
And so, you kind of, it kind
of puts a barrier, you know,
but back in the time of recordings
when we actually listened
to physical copy of things, and you
had liner notes, and you had text
and translations, and those
things were like available
without even thinking because
it was all just one thing.
You didn't have to do the extra
Googles or search or whatever.
And so, what I'm finding in my
experienced over the last decade,
since I was at Marlboro,
has been that the audiences
that love this repertoire are
the chamber music audiences
because you guys are
so knowledgeable
about every corner
of classical music.
And because there's just
not so many platforms for us
to perform this kind of music,
these audiences, you, are responding
because you think, oh
gosh, great, that's nice.
I haven't heard that in a long time.
And so, actually, I've found
that in general when trying
to promote the repertoire
in general,
first place once you turn is the
chamber music audience because it's,
it's such a welcome respite, you
know, on a program that's two hours
with just interested
in instrumental music.
>> Thank you.
>> Nicholas Brown:
Any other questions?
In the back here?
>> Hi. First, thank you so much
for the wonderful performance.
I have a question for, for the
singer, is there a particular reason
that you have decided
to choose English,
sing in English rather than German?
And if you had a chance to
sing in German, would there,
what would be the difference
as a singer?
>> Nicholas Phan: So, just today,
this program, which was developed
by Marlboro, just happened
to be English.
I would have happily sung in German.
The Beethoven songs were
intended to be sung in English.
He wrote, he set them
for the English words.
So, that's why we're
in English today.
If I were singing in German, it
would just be a little extra work
for me before I walk on stage.
I mean, that's the only thing
I would do really differently.
It's also sometimes with
German, I find that there's just
because it's not my native language,
and it's not your native language,
or most of the people in the
audience, you have to kind
of do just a little extra
work to be extra specific.
You know, English affords
you the opportunity to paint
with some broader strokes sometimes,
which because you know the
audience will, hopefully,
if I'm singing properly, understand
what's happening more easily.
So, that's, basically, it just
requires a little bit extra homework
and a little bit of extra practice.
>> Nicholas Brown:
Any other questions?
Yes, Michael.
>> Michael: Thank you.
My [inaudible] and it was wonderful
to see Marlboro here away from --
we were watching at home.
We're very grateful to the library
for hosting while our
[inaudible] was closed.
I have a pretty singer's question.
I sing in a church choir, and
listening to the Vaughan Williams,
I, of course, as an amateur singer,
we do not like singing the e-vowel
very much, especially if it's high
or loud, and listening
to Vaughan Williams,
I think I only heard
one extended e-sound.
All the rest were a, o, ah,
beautiful sounds to sing.
So, did Vaughan Williams go out
of his way, as far as you know,
or do really good composers writing
[inaudible] go out of their way
to avoid forcing that singer
to sing e-vowel loud or long?
>> Nicholas Phan: I think
just we lucked out this time
because of Housman's poetry,
there's not a lot of spaces where,
or words that involved
e on a stressed syllable
that Vaughan Williams would
have wanted to emphasize.
So, I think it's mostly luck
of the draw on this one, yes.
Unfortunately, sometimes
professional singers also do not
always like doing that, and we
are still required to sing e
for long periods of time
on high, high notes.
We just pray that it
sounds beautiful.
>> Michael: Can I ask one
more question just about that?
If I were to listen to an
English tenor, or an Irish
or Scottish tenor, and an
English or a UK Quartet,
would the pronunciation
in non-American dialect
be very different,
and then would it affect how the
string players and piano accompany?
>> Nicholas Phan: From my
perspective, I really try and go
for the British accent in these
particular songs, and I mean,
I'm an America, so I'm doing
my best Meryl Streep, you know.
That's --
[ Inaudible Comment ]
She's the master of
Excellence [phonetic].
>> I know.
>> Nicholas Phan: So,
I'm just, you know,
that's what I'm basically doing.
You might hear, obviously,
more British things.
British singers tend to
approach certain vowels
in a much darker fashion
than American singers do
because the vowels are just
darker in their accent.
But as for how that affects
you guys, I can't really say.
>> Carmit Zori: Well,
just if anything was going
to be extremely delicate, we
would, after we talk about it,
probably agree [phonetic].
>> Nicholas Phan: True.
So, probably a little bit.
But I mean, I really feel like
this music sounds a little funny
if you just go for a
completely American accent.
So, I aim for it like at least
mid-Atlantic to Meryl Streep.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Nicholas Brown: Okay.
I'm going to close out with one last
question now, but before I do that,
I just want to reiterate
what Michael said.
Michael, of course, is our colleague
over at the First [inaudible]
Galleries, and he's the head
of the Music Program and
Performing Arts Program in there.
He's been such a treat to work with
last season and this season as well
as the library has co-presented the
musicians from Marlboro concerts,
at least several of them, while
their hall is being renovated.
So, thank you to the
[inaudible] Galleries
for working with us on this project.
It's been such a treat to have the
Marlboro organization in our Hall
for a change, and I know it's
happened in the past before,
and we hope that we'll continue
to collaborate like this.
And there's all kinds of
information in your program
about the Career [inaudible]
Galleries,
information about when you
can get back into their spaces
and that kind of business.
Check out their website
and also check
out their social media presence,
which is really exciting.
They have some really
phenomenal things going
on on Instagram, I believe.
So, anyways, there's that.
And we also have one more
performance by, oh yes, Michael.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Nicholas Brown: Hopefully, yes.
So, our latest radio series just
concluded, and we're discussing
with Rita to figure out what's next.
One thing that we do hope with this
concert is that at least a portion
of it will go up online
as a webcast.
You can see one of the Marlboro
concerts from last season
on our website,
www.lsu.gov/broadcast,
and you can also see in here
Nick's recital from last season
when he was here performing
Britain and Shumann
and Bowles and Rorum [phonetic].
That's a really great concert,
so you can hear him doing
some different repertoire.
And so Marlboro is going
to be here again in March.
So, check out our website
for information about that.
If you don't have a ticket,
sign up with a Ticket Alert,
or just come to the door.
As you see, there are always empty
seats because people do not show up.
They're not committed to their
ticket orders for some reason,
but don't, we don't want you to be
discouraged by sold out notices.
Always come on down.
So, the last question, and
I'll say it's for the ladies,
since Nick got to talk
about singing.
My question is, on your tours,
maybe specific to Marlboro,
or just your own experiences,
what is your process
of adapting to the concert halls?
So, for example, on this tour,
you've been in the
Gardiner Museum's Hall,
which is that vertical box thing,
which is really funky and cool.
If anyone hasn't seen it, go see it.
It's really cool.
And in Wyle [phonetic],
and now are out here
and other exciting
venues coming up too.
>> Lydia Brown: Well, I
think, you know, as a pianist,
we have been raised to
do this our whole lives.
It's actually part of the job.
So, you know, I think
it's always a challenge.
I actually enjoy the challenge
of trying to kind of be able
to make any instrument in front
of you sound beautiful and never
to make any excuses about it.
So, I don't know, that's probably,
that's my own personal
kind of love and challenge.
Other is kind of to try
to find the instrument
and find the places that,
the way that it sings.
You know, you try to find
the soul of the instrument,
and you have usually a little
bit of time to do that.
And then, I think once you find
that, I think it's easy to find,
I think any musician has to find
that sound within themselves.
And then, I think once you
have that, and you can kind
of fit your sound around your
place, and so I think that's always,
I start with myself and
the piano sound first,
and then I think once I, then
I feel like I can open up.
But I think if I didn't do the,
if I didn't have that first,
it would be harder for me.
>> Carmit Zori: We do have to say
that tonight was a
really big spoiled.
Tonight was being spoiled.
>> Nicholas Brown: Thank you.
>> Carmit Zori: This is a Hall
that loves our instruments.
>> Yeah.
>> Carmit Zori: So, and compliments,
the audience make us feel good too.
Somehow, when you played, we felt
something in the air, and that makes
for always alleviating a
wonderful rapport in playing.
>> Nicholas Brown: Well, thank you.
We appreciate that on your behalf.
>> Michelle Ross: I think it's funny
because no matter how many Halls
you go to or rooms or galleries,
or whatever you're playing in, every
soundtrack is going to be a moment
where you have this like if you
feel like you don't have control
because it's different, and I
always try and remember that as soon
as there are bodies in the space,
99% of the time, it feels perfect,
and tonight was so special
because the Hall was amazing
when we got here, and we just
played to Carnegie on Monday, so.
>> Nicholas Brown:
Take that, New York.
>> Michelle Ross: So, we're coming
from a really beautiful experience,
and there was something so special
about, also what Carmit was talking
about in terms of the
history of this Hall.
I know she mentioned the Budapest
Quartet right before we played the
concert, and I was so moved
just thinking about that,
and not consciously while I'm
playing, but it was just feeling so.
I think in a way touring
is so special
because you don't have very
much time in all these places,
but it's you're so concentrating.
You bring so much of yourself that
you end up getting so much back,
and I thought it was so special
tonight to feel the space change
with the audience and know
what amazing legacy we're --
>> Tradition.
>> Michelle Ross: Yeah,
where, tradition,
we're so honored to be a part of.
So, that was and I think if you
can bring that mindset to any hall
and just kind of trust that it's a
part of your instrument in a way.
So, then it sort of
alleviates all of the stress.
>> Alice Yoo: Well, for me, wherever
I go, I try to make it a challenge
of being really present and aware.
So, in not a hall like this;
maybe it's not an ideal space,
then instead of focusing on what you
wish it could be or you're trying
to make something happen,
but you just sort of try
and make yourself really
present for where you are.
And then, some of that helps
me accept where I'm playing
and what my colleagues
are doing around me
and what's coming back towards me.
So, even if you're playing
Carnegie or just a hall like this,
or in a concrete box, the
experience that you're,
where you're sitting is
it'll still be a special one
because you're present.
Does that make sense?
>> Rebecca Albers: I don't
really have anything to add.
I freaked, and I think it's
always interesting to listen,
to try to listen kind of from the
outside when you're in a new space
because what's happening right
here is always a different,
it's a different experience
than if you're listening
to higher sound that's coming back.
So, it's, I really enjoy actually
playing in different halls
because it's interesting and
it's kind of a fun challenge too
for your ears and for
physicality play.
>> Nicholas Brown: Did you
want to chime in, Nick?
>> Nicholas Phan: No.
>> Nicholas Brown: Oh!
Great. Well, thank you
all for spending some time
with us after the concert.
I know it's exhausting to do
that and then have to come out
and do more in front
of the audience,
but they really appreciate it.
We really appreciate it,
and the viewers online will
definitely appreciate it as well.
And just since you mentioned the
Budapest Quartet's experience here,
being a library and an archive,
we do happen to have the
Budapest Quartet's Orca.
So, we have all of their scores
and their parts and their markings.
So, out there in YouTube
land, if you're hearing this,
you can come and copy
their markings.
Check out our website, www.lsc.gov,
and you can search
for Budapest Quartet.
You'll find recordings, all kinds
of other available materials,
and then there's a
special collection
of theirs in the Music Division.
If you're having any trouble
finding out how to access that,
just click on the Ask a Librarian
link anywhere on the website,
and you can send a direct question
to our Music Reference librarians,
and they will help you out.
They're really a fantastic bunch,
and we're the biggest Music Library
in the world, so how about that.
So, thank you again for being here.
Thank you again for being
here, and we'll look forward
to all reconvening
sometime in the future
to hear you all play some
more and sing some more.
And without further ado, off
to dinner or drinks, or bed.
So, thank you all so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at www.loc.gov